Every living being needs to fight off other
living beings that want to feast on them.​
So as multicellular life evolved over billions of
years, it came up with ways to defend itself.​
Today humans have a sophisticated defense network,​
like physical barriers, defense cells, and weapons factories.​
But one of the most important defenses
of our body is largely unknown:​
The Complement System​
It evolved over 700 million years ago and
is an army of over 30 different proteins​
that work together in a complex
and elegant dance to stop intruders.​
All in all, about 15 quintillion of them are saturating
every fluid in your body right now.​
Guided by nothing but chemistry,​
these proteins are one of the most
effective weapons we have against invaders.​
Many other parts of the immune system are just
tools to activate the Complement System.​
But it's also really dangerous.​
Imagine having trillions of little bombs inside
your blood that could go off at any moment.​
So our cells use numerous mechanisms to prevent​
​complement from accidentally attacking ​​them​.​
Okay, what exactly does it do
and what makes it so dangerous?​
In a nutshell, The Complement System does three things:​
it cripples enemies, it activates the immune system,
and it rips holes in things until they die.​
But, how?​
After all, these are mindless proteins randomly
drifting around without will or direction.​
Well, this is actually part of the strategy.​
Complement proteins float around in a sort-of passive mode.​
They do nothing, until they get activated and change their shape.​
In the world of proteins, your shape
determines what you can and cannot do.​
Because shape determines what
you can interact with and in what way.​
For example, in your passive shape you might do nothing.​
In your active shape, however, you might, for
example, change the shape of other proteins​
activating them so they can activate others.​
Mechanisms like this one can start
cascades that spread very quickly.​
Imagine the complement proteins as being like
millions of matches very close together.​
Once one catches fire, it ignites the ones around it.​
They ignite more and suddenly you have a big fire.​
To show the actual mechanisms of The Complement
System is a tad complicated and overwhelming.​
So, we'll simplify here.​
Now, let's imagine you cut yourself
and a bunch of bacteria enter the wound​
and make it into the surrounding tissue.​
Our complement attack begins with C3.​
C3 is the first match, the initial spark that will start our fire.​
And to do that, C3 needs to switch from passive to active.​
How this happens is complex, but
let's just say it can happen randomly​
through other complement proteins that
bind to enemies or through antibodies.​
All you really need to know is that
C3 breaks into two smaller proteins,​
C3a and C3b, that are now activated.​
One of these parts, the C3b protein, is like a seeker
missile specialized in bacteria, fungi, and viruses.​
It has a fraction of a second to find a victim
or it will be neutralized by water molecules.​
If C3b does find a target, it anchors itself very
tightly to its surface and doesn't let go.​
By doing so, the protein changes its shape again.​
In its new shape, it's now able to grab
other proteins and start a small cascade,​
changing its shape multiple times,
adding other complement proteins to itself.​
Finally, it transforms itself into a recruiting
platform known as C3 Convertase.​
This platform is an expert at activating more
C3 proteins that start the whole cycle anew.​
An amplification loop begins.​
Soon, thousands of proteins cover the bacteria.​
For the bacteria, this is very bad.​
It can cripple the bacteria and make
them helpless, or slow them down.​
Imagine being covered by thousands of flies.​
But, there's more.​
Do you remember the other part of C3—the C3a protein?​
C3a is like a distress beacon.​
Thousands of them flood away from
the site of battle screaming for attention.​
Passive immune cells notice the C3a proteins,​
and awaken from their slumber to follow
the protein tracks to the site of infection.​
The more alarm proteins they encounter,
the more aggressive they get.​
This way, complement guides reinforcements
exactly to the place where they're needed the most.​
So far, the complement has slowed
down the invaders and called for help.​
Now, it's beginning to actively help to kill the enemy.​
The first immune cells to arrive at the battlefield are ​​phagocytes​.​
Which means, cells that swallow you whole, trap
you in a tiny prison, and then kill you with acid.​
But, to swallow an enemy, they need to grab it first.​
Which is not easy because bacteria prefer
not to be grabbed and are sort-of slippery.​
But now, the complement that has
anchored itself to the bacteria​
acts as a sort-of glue that makes it easy
for the immune cells to catch their victims.​
But it gets even better.​
Imagine being covered in flies again.​
Now, imagine them turning into wasps.​
Another cascade is about to begin.​
On the surface of a bacteria, the C3
recruitment platform changes its shape again​
and begins to recruit new proteins.​
Together, they begin the construction of a bigger
structure: a Membrane Attack Complex.​
Piece-by-piece, new proteins shaped like long spears
anchor themselves deep into the bacteria's membranes,​
until they rip a hole into them that can't be closed again.​
Fluids rush into the bacteria and their insides spill out.​
They bleed to death.​
The remaining bacteria are maimed
and distracted by the complement,​
and quickly taken care of by the arriving immune cells.​
The invasion has been nipped in the bud before
it had the opportunity to become dangerous.​
You probably didn't even notice it.​
But while bacteria are not happy about complement,​
the enemies it might be the most
useful against are actually viruses.​
Viruses have one problem:
they need to travel from cell to cell.​
Outside of cells, they're basically hoping to randomly
bump against a cell to infect by pure chance.​
Here, they're completely defenseless.​
And here, complement is able to intercept and cripple them,​
so they become harmless and guide
the immune system to devour them.​
Without complement, virus
infections would be a lot more deadly.​
But wait, if we have such an effective
weapon, why do we ever get sick?​
The problem is that in a war, both sides adapt.​
For example, when the ​​vaccinia virus​ infects a cell,​
it forces it to produce a protein
that shuts complement activation down.​
This way, the virus creates safe
zones around the cells it infects.​
When it kills them, and tries to infect more,
it has a higher chance of being successful.​
Or some bacteria, for example, can grab certain molecules
from the blood that keep the complement system calm​
and make themselves invisible.​
So the complement system,
while being extremely important,​
is only one player in the complex and beautiful
organization that is our immune system.​
A beautiful example of how many
mindless things can do smart things together.​
This video was sponsored by ​​you​.​
Without your direct support, this channel would not exist.​
And it's hard to overstate how grateful we are for that.​
In 2019, an average kurzgesagt video
took at least 1200 hours to produce.​
We need months to research and write
our scripts, clear them with experts,​
illustrate and animate every scene from
scratch, and to compose original music.​
This is only possible through a combination of sponsorships,​
your support on Patreon, and selling merch​
like this poster and postcards we
made about The Complement System.​
If you, yourself, want to support us,​
you can do so by watching, becoming a Patreon,
and maybe getting a personal bird.​
Or, by getting one of our calendars or posters.​
The purpose of kurzgesagt is
to make the best videos we can​
and to make science more approachable.​
Thank you so much for making this possible.​
​​